[Music]
when you find a tree that has an apple
and just discovering new varieties it's
just I mean I live for that
I'm Annie Brennan my wife and I we
around our town and we forage for wild
apples and we make it into a series of
ciders based on where the apples are
located you sell at the Gramercy Tavern
yeah yeah Gramercy Tavern which I've
only not once
I know it's famous and especially their
wine menu is somewhat famous having
cider made from wild forged fruit is
really unusual something that can only
be done in very small amounts what comes
out of the bottle is really special
[Music]
we go out into the woods we go to places
where apples are not at all influenced
by human cultivation we're searching the
woods and sometimes it's difficult to
find the trees man if the light doesn't
hit the silver and the trunk just right
you may not even know it's an apple tree
you're in luck when you find not just
one or two but a whole forest of trees
which sometimes does exist what I love
is discovering varieties that are just
so peculiar you would never find them in
a grocery store the other day we found
an apple that has red flesh so you bite
into it and it just looks like a
pomegranate they're telling us process
takes about four hours to grind and
press enough juice to fill a barrel
think of those barrels as bears its
hibernating nine months after you
collected the apples that's when it's
ready
[Music]
these Santa's are all really kids at
heart they like the fun and laughter
that comes with it and making people
happy that's why we're here you ask them
why they're staying up most of them will
tell you because they enjoyed being a
child so they're going back to that
they're reliving your childhood it's a
wonderful thing
welcome everyone to the Charles W Howard
80th anniversary Santa Claus school
[Applause]
[Music]
you better watch out you better not cry
I'm telling you why Santa Claus my name
is Tom Valenti I'm the Dean of the
Charles W Howard is Santa Claus school
in Midland Michigan this is the Harvard
Isana school it's the oldest running
Santa Claus School in the world started
by Charlie Howard in 1937 at Santa Claus
school we learned everything from beard
keeping to personal hygiene toy making
to what it feels like to ride on the
Polar Express flying the sleigh Santa
has to be healthy he's a healthy
outdoorsman if you're not healthy you're
gonna drift off you're not gonna pay
attention it's very important to have
all the skills you can to be a great
Santa because the child is gonna
remember this visit for the rest of your
life when Charlie had the school he had
three or four students some good years
maybe 15 students this year we have 214
it just grows
we have Santa's of course from almost
every state in the United States we have
around 20 Santa's from Canada we have
three Santa's from Denmark one from
Norway and one from Germany there's a
real sense of camaraderie in this school
it's like this large Santa family coming
together they share stories they learn
from each other we want to be Santa's to
make people happy when we get together
we're making each other happy I love it
once they leave this school I hope that
each and every Santa and mrs. Claus goes
out and spreads the spirit of Christmas
spreads the love and joy that we have
here at this school and passes it on to
all the little children and all the
families when you give joy you get it
back to fold so we got you something Oh
what is it
come on open it up oh okay thanks
no honestly this little guy is a big
deal in Catalonia to explain why we got
a head to toe fellow demanding leave a
town in the Catalonia region of Spain
and to Barcelona a little later but
anyways back to Tahoe le de menthe agree
home to this man known in a way this one
pasha yellows the Haqqanis tiger
what gah gah net colony una persona que
está siendo shows necesidad a agora in
english at - [ __ ] poor ankara name
appear family traditional way and we
catalana in Catalonia when you put up
your nativity scene you have Mary Joseph
of course baby Jesus some kings and this
guy yep The Keg Amer
tenemos que hace lo de hecho para
encontrar una súplica
yellow tag on a philosophy cidades con
el campo portal de fertility Yavana la
la tierra oh no dinero Karenina
very important Ventura Milosh Huerta so
in someone's home
there he is in this museum there he is
well there's even one in the street
nativity scene okay this is definitely
not a joke can we now talk about your
latest business idea estás mark my
hermano
yes Tam Barcelona I have in the end oh
yeah Taurus colony's desde que le [ __ ]
mascara
Anastas persona has no Kampala Tico's
food ballistas creme de la cultura la
demanda kahani no fue so viendo el
principio un poco de incredulous no de
que esto no despues cuando la un poquito
la tradición pues si la mera no otra
manera a Mucha gente que VA a comprar la
collection is Amira's que tengo una city
la parte de la la ba e que cuando voy
Mikio sentir accompanied oh no he is
reporting a lava see there you go a gift
for all year round
everybody knows jolly old Saint Nick
he's the bearer of good tidings and
cheer well in Austria he's not alone and
we don't mean Rudolph
[Music]
these are Krampus a sort of monster that
travels with Saint Nick they scare away
bad spirits and look for naughty kids to
punish making Christmas a whole lot
scarier people in Europe have been
welcoming the Christmas season by
dressing his Krampus for hundreds of
years
I am Ralph Hetzel and I am the oldest
Krampus here in town out Market and the
fifth of December we came to the child
in their homes and the good one gets
some sweets from the nicolò and the pept
ones get hit with the whip from the
Krampus then we go from house to house
for five six hours and after we recently
to all the children in out mark there's
a little run with all Krampus together
[Music]
the story of Saint Nick and Krampus goes
back to 375 ad and the costumes and
traditions haven't changed much since
the dress from the Krampus is made of
wool from the Sheep the masks are made
of wood and so when you're walking
around to all the children to their
houses for some hours you really will
get sweat it's a likely work out it's
funny to go into the houses from the
people their reaction is different some
child's are not scared come to you and
grab to affair in other ones screaming
and running away the Krampus is a good
reason to change their mind from the
children try to be good for the next
year I am dressed as Krampus this year
the 15-time I'm very lucky to go every
year I'm very proud to be a part of this
whole tradition
[Music]